[Music]
hi how goes it
I was just looking for Gordon Ramsay
over my shoulder cuz this is his kitchen
welcome to Ramsay Redemption my name is
Monte Carlo and this is the coolest show
ever because I get to make over your
mistakes sorta here's the deal you tweet
pictures of your nasty food at Gordon
Ramsay and then you'll text me pictures
of that food and what in the world is
this okay this is a tweet from daechan
but it's biscuits and gravy from her
school look at this disgusting dish the
biscuits of dry AF the sausages are like
the very tiniest specials of poop
alright
Ramsay redemption let's go the first
thing we're gonna do is make buttermilk
for our buttermilk biscuits how do you
make buttermilk it's very easy you take
one tablespoon of acid - one cup of
regular whole milk it can be lemon juice
or I can just be distilled white vinegar
okay you're gonna take that you're gonna
stir it up you see how it's already
thickened Hello buttermilk that was easy
now I'm gonna set that in the fridge to
stay cool because when you're making
biscuits everything has to stay cold
that's the most important thing next
step flour this is just regular
all-purpose flour we are going to add
baking powder to it whisk it a little
bit we're gonna add a pinch of salt
because you want to add seasoning at
every level this is my favorite thing to
do in the whole wide world
a frozen stick of butter and we're gonna
grate it in a food processor press down
and watch how fast this goes
Oh God okay it's easy but it can get
messy that's alright I'm making biscuits
why do you want chunks of butter because
this is gonna give you fun layers in
your biscuits it's already soft though
so you have to be careful keep your
hands out of this why because you're
alive and if you're alive you're warm
mix it up with the flour so the flour
coats the butter that was pretty
stinking easy right in the fridge
waiting is the hardest part but you must
wait ten minutes until that butter is
nice and firm again and it's just about
time
hey this is something your lunch lady is
not doing and that's making her own
dough we are going to make a well in the
center pouring our buttermilk
[Music]
and then gently gently gently folding
the flour into the buttermilk oh my
goodness dough has already started to
form hello
how easy is that we are going to lightly
flour our work surface and we are gonna
take our dough I am making dough but I'm
doing it as quickly as possible because
my hands are very warm and I don't want
to melt that butter
hello biscuit dough I think I love you
all right we're gonna fold this dough
like a business letter five times and
again
[Music]
all right we've got this dough all sorts
covered up in plastic and now we're
gonna let it rest for another ten
minutes
I just left floured fingerprints all
over Gordon Ramsey's very clean kitchen
our dough has rested I know because it's
nice and firm now and we're just gonna
take this to about a half an inch
thickness take your biscuit cutter if
you don't have a biscuit cutter just see
you can just make sure that you cover
the rim and flour so it doesn't stick to
the dough listen this is a tricky part
this is the part where most people fuss
it all up straight down all right that's
it no twisting okay straight down and
then put it on your pan when you twist
you ruin all those amazing layers you
just create it why do that notice also
how I am putting all of these biscuits
really close together biscuits like to
give each other hugs and when they hug
they help each other rise now we're
gonna put these biscuits in a 425-degree
oven but not before showing them a
little extra love you're gonna take a
brush dip it into some heavy cream and
then brush the tops of your biscuits
with the heavy cream look at these
beauties they are ready to go 425
degrees right so while those biscuits
bake off in about ten to twelve minutes
they're gonna be golden perfection we
are gonna make the gravy part of
biscuits and gravy
we want this pan to be screamin hot so
when the sausage hits it it starts to
develop caramelization you can use your
favorite sausage I'm going for pork
sausage because I'm Puerto Rican and
it's our favorite flavor you're gonna
want to slice this up some otherwise
you're gonna get big old chunks of pork
in your sausage gravy and that's no fun
oh my goodness oh look at those bird
spots do you see them that's where all
the flavor is
let it burn a little bit that's gonna
create color in your gravy you want that
you don't want it to be that ashen
disgusting
Casper looking hot mess okay this is
ready to go we're gonna reserve the fat
to make our gritted first you're going
to add 3 tablespoons of flour mix it
right in if you don't have enough fat in
the pan to make a paste just add a
little butter all right this kids are
done babe yes let's get back to our
gravy we're gonna add in our milk you
don't want to stop whisking
just getting a gravy facial everyone see
how it's thickened incredible so easy
man that's arms day right there covered
oh and G is that the most ridiculous
yummy gravy you've ever seen don't even
act you would eat this every single day
for breakfast lunch and dinner even your
lunch like I need to have a talk melted
butter so important as a finishing touch
oh yeah give it a little shine babe this
is like lip gloss
now layers
that's what frozen butter does go ahead
and slice these down the middle it's
time to plate put a cup of biscuits down
look at the incredible color on this
gravy we're gonna just drizzle it on top
yes cover cover cover beauteous biscuit
and gravy redeemed come on Dave you give
your lunch lady my Twitter handle her
night we gotta have a talk more
importantly let's see what Gordon Ramsay
has to say about these you've got the
Midas touch thanks so much for watching
Ramsay redemption if you have a dish and
you'd like redeem it's as easy as taking
a picture or video of it and putting it
in our Twitter feed with the hashtag
Ramsey redemption should you put your
hands in a pan not if you like them